48 hours is talking with a key figure in
a case of murder and alleged fraud
involving a prominent south carolina
family attorney alex murdoch is charged
with trying to have himself killed in
order to get 10 million dollars in
insurance money for his son now three
months earlier his wife and an other son
were shot to death that case is still
unsolved at this time but his lawyer
tells wh tv that murdoch is a person of
interest while insisting he did not kill
them
murdoch told investigators we have to
follow along here that he hired a man
named curtis smith to shoot him in the
head last month murdoch claims he's been
addicted he's been addicted rather to
opioids for 20 years and smith is his
drug dealer now smith tells his side of
the story for the first time this
morning to nikki batiste it's a 48 hours
interview
you've been called the hillbilly hitman
how does that make you feel i laugh at
it
i really do curtis smith says it was
september 4th when his friend south
carolina attorney alex murdoch called
claiming he needed help smith says
murdoch was like a brother to him so he
didn't think twice before heading to
meet him when smith arrived on a stretch
of road he says murdoch emerged from his
car holding a gun
he's down there like this
he said yeah you got take care of this i
said
well i can't do it
he told me he turned his head i just
grabbed his arm put it behind his head
to the gun for me smith claims during
that struggle the gun went off then he
disposed of the weapon he wanted me to
kill him to make it look like a suicide
manhattan of course curtis is like
anybody else are you insane what are you
doing johnny mccoy is smith's lawyer
made sure he couldn't kill himself
and no crime no crime if i hadn't took
the gun out of what he would have done
that's simple after the struggle smith
says he ran off and went home how are
you feeling as this was happening as
you're driving away
mad
scared
all at one time no crime was committed
yeah right some people would think well
he tried to kill himself is that a crime
no i guess or you call 9-1-1 some people
think call 9-1-1 because it's but the
gun got taken out of his hand why on
earth would you call the police let
alone on alex murdoch when nothing what
are you going to say hey this guy was
suicidal but murdock's original version
of the events was much different from
smith's he initially told investigators
he was changing a flat tire when a
driver passed by and shot him in the
head he was taken to a nearby hospital
for a superficial gunshot wound murdoch
now says he asked curtis smith to meet
him on the side of the road and help him
take his own life hoping his life
insurance would be paid out to his only
surviving son
murdoch's attorney at the time of his
arrest said his client was addicted to
opioids and that it had taken a toll on
his mental health a fact smith took
advantage of he says when he agreed to
take murdock's life
according to murdoch's attorney murdoch
had grown more distraught in the months
following his sons and wife's unsolved
murder at their home in june did you
shoot alex murdoch no
were you alex murdock's drug dealer no
if you're guilty of anything what is it
trusting too much
are you innocent yes
for cbs mornings i'm nikki batiste in
myrtle beach south carolina
number one i'm fascinated nikki even got
an interview with him at this particular
time because his case as you know is
still unfolding she says that smith says
he has no hard feelings for murdoch
because he thinks he's a man who went
through a rough time after his wife and
son were killed it was a very bizarre
story from the very beginning and the
more you hear the more strange it gets
and i have sympathy for anyone who's
going through a problem with addiction
uh the question is not sympathy the
question is where crime's committed it's
a heck of an interview yeah and the more
you pull back the layers there's so many
different aspects to this and the deaths
before the attempted murder on the side
of the road absolutely a lot going on a
lot going on story well you'll hear more
of nikki's interview in fact the rest of
nikki's interview with curtis smith on
an upcoming episode of 48 hours right
here on cbs